calls are mounting for the resignation
and potential impeachment of the south
dakota attorney general
jason ravensberg after he struck and
killed a man with his car
this is an absolutely bonkers legal case
where
last year ravensburg admitted to
striking a man with his car
he said he was doing nothing wrong and
it was just one of those freak accidents
but the evidence seems to show that the
victim
actually flew through the man's
windshield leaving his eyeglasses
inside the interior of the car then
ravensburg went back the next day and
found that the man had passed away
ravensburg claims that he wasn't
drinking and was paying attention but
the daily beast reports
that it seems that based on the internet
traffic of his phone ravensburg was
actually reading conspiracy theories
about joe biden at the time that he was
driving and struck
and killed the man this is an absolute
bonkers investigation it's clear why
people are calling for his resignation
or impeachment from the top law
enforcement job so
we may see him in court just like we'll
see you in court if you don't subscribe